welcome back to new rockstars i'm philip
molina this is fitness origins it's a
fitness competition show inspired by the
movies of the mcu and this week
we're gonna do things a little
differently
hey eric hi um what is going on
what where's uncle tommy what did you do
to uncle tommy
hey phillip uh where is eric why what's
he getting a special one-on-one
training with chris evans what's going
on here why is he always getting special
favorite treatment from you
why don't you want me to succeed don't
tell me he's just on a farm somewhere i
know what that means
look the theme of this week is civil war
and i thought long and hard about how
antithetical it is to force you to
attack each other throughout the week a
huge part of fitness
is all about the support you have from
those around you and i know that
you and tommy are in close communication
every week throughout the week
lifting each other up yeah that's very
true we occasionally face time and i'm
not gonna lie i may have prayed for him
a few times okay well
that's all great so it seems like it
would be a major bummer to remove that
yeah yeah i i need my my buddy tommy to
help me get through this
well i i did remember something though
because even though cap and tony are
fundamentally at odds in their beliefs
about the second
accords they aren't alone in their
beliefs at that same time though so
here's where the theme of this week is
going to come in i know you love tommy
i know you love eric but you gotta
wonder who
else do you have in your corner that can
help support you
in case you don't have that exact
partner who's going through the exact
same thing as you
in any given week so who's on your side
i want you to go reach out to your other
friends your neighbors your family
let's see how you can create your own
team of avengers
those who specifically believe in and
root for you
try to recruit them to your side maybe
maybe get them to
join in on a workout or even just check
in on each other's health
i could do that yeah i've got some other
avengers it's not all about just smoke
show eric voss
sure he's the main event but i got other
people in my corner you know
kelly's definitely on my side darla is
sometimes on my side so when i try to
plank in the room she comes in and licks
my face and it feels a little mean
but good support and everyone darla is
my dog i don't have some other woman
named darla who comes
and licks my face i got a guy that sells
me
uh vape pens that has taken an active
interest in my health as i've been
smoking less i've got a
i've got a guy uh that works at an
italian deli that always sneaks me a
little extra pepperoni
uh and that's not your parents your
parents
uh that's gonna be a little tougher we
haven't been in touch
uh no i'm just kidding uh yeah okay i
could call my mom and dad eric i should
say that i know that this is
like a little bit easier for you because
you have you have kelly who is
also very active and your family is
active and it's just a lot harder for
tommy to be honest
uh so i really want to see him build
that support system for himself i mean
that that's
legitimately why i go like a little bit
easier on him when he
cheats on a meal here there or something
he just kind of needs that you know
cheats on a meal here or there like i
know there was there's a moment a couple
weeks ago where he
ate some chocolate it really it was just
like a chocolate coin that your mom sent
you
that's right yes i'm sorry i yelled at
you
thank you seriously letting him okay all
right okay
noted has he cheated on more meals than
that i mean
uh the chocolate coin yeah was with it
but like no like like but that's not the
point the point is
he he doesn't need to he doesn't need
every meal wait wait perfectly
how many meals has tommy cheated on hold
on i'm sticking to every meal how many
meals has he cheated on
i'm not going to answer that look i
think you're i think you're immediately
overthinking this
you you're not competing with him what i
try to do each week is i'm grade you
guys against yourselves
and that's all i want i want you to do
is just kind of be assessing against
yourself now you know are you doing
better than tommy okay all right i guess
that's fair do you even remember what
the theme of this week is
yeah revenge it is not revenge
you're supposed to call your friends all
right get your own avengers together
that's a we're gonna have a team eric
and uh
it's gonna be darla and kelly and yes
yes
okay spiderman okay yes if you know i
know
i know him so i just
talked to eric what would you say to
neither
of us doing our workouts we both kind of
agreed we've been working
really hard for the last six weeks we
both have been
busting our asses maybe the best thing
for our bodies would be to
kind of do a rest week we deserve a
break we're not going to tell philip so
if you don't work out
i won't work out either what do you say
i'm actually going to do all my workouts
this week
so yeah i told eric i agree we'll take
it easy this week but i
lied to him he's won two in a row i
gotta win one of these challenges so
i'm actually gonna go twice as hard so
i'm about to get on the bike i already
did my other workout for today i'm gonna
take a nice long jog this evening and i
might even end the night with a swim so
joke's on you eric see you at jack's
town
all right week seven day two vlog i
think i'm successfully fooling tommy
into not working out tuesday i laid in
bed all day very sore
from all of the uh bike rides and jogs
and we actually lifted free weights for
the first time in a year so that was not
good not smart you got to pace yourself
in these things
i should have just agreed to the deal i
should have agreed to not move if tommy
would have agreed to not move
what was i thinking back today i got up
at uh 7 in the morning to do a peloton
might do another one later today but i'm
gonna take it easy
just work as much as my body tells me to
work and not overdo it again
this is my first day doubling up on the
full round of mountain climbers first
time in seven weeks
that i've gotten through all rounds of
it and then double round to that
without having to stop in the middle of
it i mean look i'm proud of myself for
achieving the mountain climber goal
that i never thought i would hit i'm not
at all proud of myself for starting the
civil war with tommy
he's a good man i am still incredibly
sore so i think the traditional workout
route isn't going to cut it so
unfortunately i didn't want to do this
but it is civil war
so i'm going to have to go with the
nuclear option on eric i'm a little
worried that after this
we may not be friends anymore but i i do
love winning
so eric you're getting what's coming to
you
so normally i would ask how this week
went
but i've been watching your guys's vlogs
i am incredibly disappointed in both of
you what were you thinking
phil this is war yeah civil war brother
against brother you're not on your best
behavior during a civil war
you're getting the job done i went out
of my way to find
a way to make it about well you find
your own themes you call you'll call
your parents
and your siblings it's a civil war
you're simple with each other that's not
what a civil war is and besides no one
remembers that theme from four days ago
or if you're watching this video from uh
six minutes ago yeah it's a long time to
remember something war as hell philip
there's no time in war time stands still
on the battlefield
i can't think of which one of you i'm
more upset with well then pick
eric cause he's handsomer well pick
tommy because he's
nicer about complimenting people for
being handsome uh i don't want to pick
either of you also tommy's also on my
[ __ ] list even though he's usually nicer
you sent eric
food well you know i had a couple of
treacherous plans this week that blew up
in my face a little bit
so i had to call in the big gun so yeah
i used uh
gorgash to uh get eric's importos did
you say gordash
no gorgash gorgash masha hagian he's an
armenian guy that
rides a bicycle around my town and if
you give him nickels
sometimes wooden sometimes metal he'll
deliver whatever you want you just go
gargash
and he shows up so i had him go to
porto's and bring eric some stuff
i was wondering who sent me this i was
gonna tweet like don't you guys know
that i am in
a weight loss challenge one you thought
a fan found out where you live and sent
you food
two did you eat it no okay
whether or not the driver was gorgeous
or named gorgash
you you did use doordash though right
yes of course i used doordash
beautiful sponsors yes maybe
uh you will continue to use doordash
because you did just inspire me
uh sending food to each other you guys
are gonna need to pay it forward
oh you'd order a doordash meal this week
and i want you to
to pay for it so you're probably going
to want to use our 25 off zero delivery
fee code of nerd fitness it has to be
your first order by the way it has to be
15
more subject to change term supply but
download the door dash app enter code
nerd fitness and i want you to send a
nice meal to someone else someone who
could use some cheering up
you guys are all in a karma hole right
now and you can use some good karma
for those of you listening i actually do
this with my friends pretty often i
add their addresses to my list of
delivery locations at doordash and then
i send them over like
fun food when they've got something to
celebrate or they've got something hard
going on so i send them the hard stuff
and you know i sometimes when i've
messed up i send someone
fun food and the hard stuff either way
do that for yourself or for somebody
else you can do it all with contactless
delivery download the thor dash app 25
off your first order and no delivery
fees just make sure to use our code
nerdfitness so we get a little bit of
that karma god knowing that we're
involved in some way too you two however
just need to do
this to make up for how horrible you
were this week working late editing a
falcon in the winter soldier breakdown
and i got a text from eric saying that
there's a surprise at the door so
um he sent me some dinner
i had a delicious burger and then i got
a text
like 20 minutes later from tommy so you
got a surprise
at the door
what am i going to do with all this
good thing i have roommates guys what do
you guys want for your cheat meals this
week even though i'm hesitating even
allowing you to have one at all
i am dying for tacos phillip i'm diver
tacos too
okay well then let's get specific so
tommy you want i want
fish tacos from tres hermanos which
stands for three herman's
eric uh what uh what kind of tacos would
you like
um i want a specific kind i want to be
nice greasy street chicken tacos
but with flour tortillas there's a
couple places in the valley that do
homemade flour tortillas and i want
flour because i want it to have lard in
it
it's not a good taco for me if it's on
anything else
so uh we'll see you guys do
tomorrow's challenge and who will
actually win the week even though i'm
still upset with you
you know what let's get limber but get
ready because we're gonna today's gonna
be a tough workout let's get up guys
[Music]
my son eric my other son
join me won't you
[Applause]
would you like some tea oh yeah sure
[Music]
so rich and creamy that's just yeah okay
as you know the time has come for the
doctor strange challenge and with
doctor strange we have the ability to
focus on a different kind of fitness
specifically inspired by eastern
philosophies oh
no you're not gonna make us do something
racist are you it's only racist if
you're white
good good okay so dr strange finds
that most of his training actually needs
to come with getting to know
himself and his own limits focusing in
on the power of meditation
before being ready for battle in the
multiverse with a giant head of dormammu
for this challenge you're going to be
caught in your own time loop
completing a simple enough task just a
yoga pose
over and over again however to make it a
little more
trippy i decided to get you high oh oh i
knew this drink was weird
unfortunately i legitimately looked into
this and insurance would not cover that
so instead we're gonna get you high in a
natural way involving another kind of
loop y'all are basically gonna be
spinning around as part of each loop
looking dizzy yes exactly so each loop
you'll have to hold tree post for three
seconds
of course the challenge is going to get
progressively harder since you'll be
adding one additional spin for each of
the loops and it won't be your mambo
you've come to bargain with
it'll actually be your opponent and
yourself because
whoever makes the other person quit
first wins the challenge
also please do not throw up in the
astral plane it is very hard to clean up
also insurance would not cover that
either i wouldn't hate a little more of
this
tea do not drink the creamer it's got oh
that was just creamer
i housed that okay you guys ready get
the [ __ ] out of my sanctum
thank you please
[Music]
are you ready to bargain with each other
yes
yes we've come to bargain yeah i know i
just said that
we are ready we're just yeah we're doing
some meisner [ __ ] we're excited
as always i am satisfied by specifically
tree pose
let's begin
was that even three seconds way more
than three seconds well i held it longer
than he did so well because i was trying
to make you feel good on
who's getting his iphone timer all right
one loop
one loop
i'm ready to make a deal you want to get
out of here no i'm not ready to make a
deal
no deal okay all right let's do it two
ready two
goddamn it i could do this all day
[Music]
all right okay so have you come to
bargain no
never
great i'll make a deal with you all
right if you give up and say that i win
i'll do double workouts next week
double workouts next week but then it'll
make you stronger for the next week's
stretch
no deal eric i have a small note can you
do real spins like the way tommy's doing
i'm doing ballet and trust me i'm not
getting anything out of this i don't
know if you feel fine i could do 10 more
of these in a row no bargain you punch
all right fine great let's do 10 more
we're going to 20. all right find a 20.
[Music]
well done thomas
yes join me boys how do y'all feel i
could
use a cup of that tea that was milk
it came up at one point do you feel more
connected with yourself spiritually i
feel connected
centered really aligned i'm really glad
to hear that tommy
but for the challenge tommy is
eric you're not acting very happy or are
you just centered
sure i'm centered for me my stomach is
centered in my [ __ ] right now from
all that spinning you made us do so
there's that
well luckily you won't have to worry
about that sweet sweet door that cheat
meal
or will you he might because the math
actually could work out in either of
their favors depending on who did a
better job this week
with their exercise and their diet time
to get a tabulating
and you two can get the [ __ ] out of my
sanctum again
again with the hospitality go go
let's go let's go
[Music]
all right boys how you feeling about
that doctor strange multiverse you just
visited
i never want to go back to the
multiverse knows it was a
fairly straightforward uh kind of
torture and bananas but uh it does feel
like you guys kind of earned your way
into that challenge this week huh we'll
never fight again
daddy phillip i'll be good daddy daddy
daddy phil phil
i don't like the daddy thing but it was
clear that one of you
did do better than the other not during
the week you guys both were offered
anyway but one of you did better during
the challenge but you don't know which
of you
won the overall week so go get your
meals your door dash drivers are waiting
i'm gonna explain to the audience how we
chose our winner so we should have known
with eric's
zemo dance moves that he would end up
being the baron zemo of the civil war
episode sabotaging tommy was the exact
opposite
of what i wanted them to do but tommy
also did
have a lesser workout week than usual he
also ended up trying to sabotage eric
too
but when it came to the challenge i
really saw how much
tommy tried to make up for the week i
mean look at the velocity of that
spinning
so the overall winner for this week is
well actually
they don't exactly know yet so
who won i think i did no no no my friend
the fishes have arise then what is mine
these are tacos but it's corn tortillas
i still have really said flour i want
lard i mean yes i went out of my way to
not do flour because corn is uh much
healthier are you eating it already
it's not it looks like chicken but it's
not i think it's made completely
from a vegetable thing you gave me fake
chicken
that whole thing you're eating is only
about 100 calories this is me
yeah you you cheated and you lied this
week and
you also lost all right well how are you
guys uh liking your your cheat meal on
your healthy meal
this is terrific bass i wish it had more
calories for a cheat meal but i gotta
say
it's pretty good i don't know if i'll
get it again but
i don't mind it can we uh can we bury
the hatchet guys
yes eric i'm sorry i love you i'm sorry
tommy i i love you too okay either way i
wanted both of you to apologize to me
more it's my week that you guys ruined
your week well what did you do i worked
really hard on
finding a way to make civil war peaceful
well i'm glad you two are no longer
fighting
also for those of you that have been
asking yes finally right around now
those workouts that eric and tommy have
been doing are now available for you to
do
along with them you can stop asking
where they are they're there on the
youtube channel epic hero fitness
uh uh so sorry for the delays but go
ahead
and watch those videos they're meant to
be
very much for beginners please modify
them
eric and tommy both use modifications i
use a lot of the modifications too
it's just about getting off the couch
and getting moving that's all we're
trying to do
but if you're doing this please send in
a picture with
fitness origins and we'll feature you on
this show remember this whole
thing it's not just us it also could be
your origin story too
also please just share these videos if
you think they're fun have a good one
bye bye and find your
enemy that you can sabotage by
lying in deceit there's someone out
there for everyone
[Music]
you